this is a challenging question what
makes this challenging you need to use
binomial theorem in order to answer this
question however you don't get given at
least on the face of it a binomial it's
not binomial sr what we've got it's not
two it's three terms so you would call
it a try to I guess none of that matters
but that's what you're looking at okay
now because it's not a binomial inverted
colors they give you a clue in the
question itself right we want you to get
this and we say treat it like this okay
now I'll just point out if we wanted to
make this question more challenging we
put it at the end of the paper rather
than like a half way through if you
encounter a question like this at the
end it would be totally fair for us to
just give you the original question
without the clues without the clues
because when you think about it you're
like okay I know binomial theorem
that's this theorem that I know you can
see the clear clue that this is a Bible
to your question is number one is asking
about coop bishops talking [ __ ] that's
what my name is who is all about and
secondly look at that power of they're
so powerful clearly don't intend for you
to just expand the whole thing out you
only give a let you access these numbers
of extensions in binomial theorem so
there are enough clues in the question
as written that you need to use binomial
theorem in some way which means okay
well I'm going to have to identify I'm
going to turn that thing which is not a
binomial right now into a binomial in
some way okay it does make sense
plus two plus x rather carry it the
other way why would you pair the way
that is suggestive rather say have one
of them be two and wanted to be x times
x squared
why would you do this well yeah it's
just going to become a disaster
to try and deal with this and this
together as you'll see in a minute so
it's better to pair these up it's
simpler and then leave this complicated
one it's even got the negative sign as
well - known as machine
so that's why they have rightly
suggested as the way to go through now
let's start with what people did
reasonably well on this question and out
of a three marks the street right and a
three months of discretion which is
where people tended to get their one and
only mark if you think of this as this
and this you can write this use the
extinct meditation okay now I'll make a
quick note about communication I think
you guys did a better job of this think
most of the cohort but we didn't do it
perfectly surprisingly synchronization
requires a sleeper in it okay this is
like a really important part of serial
attention just why it's called that
right you have to ride this out the
front because you're saying look I think
I'm going to put here I'm just going to
put one term and I want to whole bunch
of them right also see meditation
requires batteries right you're going
from the first time to the laughter what
are the present lockers for this case
you're 0 for ok so I'm going to add up
and now I'm going to stay what the
general term is in a bottle especially
they're always three pieces what's the
first one if the NCRC I would record a
binomial coefficient in this case what
is in which roll on on the fourth right
now here again with a point of confusion
and I get like it's a big key concept in
you
it's terminology which is not used to
using here a lot of people put 0 so the
next step why didn't they do that they
just have this a bit much right and also
it is the first one so people put 0 no
but it's not for C 0 it's for C R
because this is one of the things that
changes as you go from terms of terms
right so it's variable so that's why I
disagree okay for the next part
IRA send them in three parts three
components you're going to have varying
powers of these components here okay so
I want you to have a think about it
remember a binomial expansion can be
written in two different orders right
when one of them having the power is
increasing and the other one that power
is decreasing now I want you to look at
the terms we're gonna have to deal with
here is this turn and then then mister
which would you like to make the
increasing power and which we should
like to make the decrease in power what
do you think makes the most sense who
wants to make 2 plus X the increase in
power which is R so V 0 1 2 3 4 anyone
you did 2 plus X let's just think about
if I made this well if I make is are
right when that make the other compose
or - that's the other component there
and how would we do this
now if you actually go about it this way
let's think about each of these pieces
and how difficulty easy are they are to
understand ok this guy here this guy
here I know how to expose what we've
been actually working it on that
recently okay so Kimmy the power is
going to multiply across so this is
going to count down 4 3 2 1 0 and then
you're just going to multiply that by
however many negative X squares you've
got they by the way note where the sign
is not out the front
inside okay that's not too challenging
if you want to deal with this
it just gets confusing when you think
about like this had nothing to interact
with on the internet it's a pair of
terms okay only why don't you put your
hand up but feel the way that I would do
it leave the simplest way okay now
people got to this line to be honest you
shouldn't really have received the mark
for this line because if you have
actually immediately preceding question
this skill was being assessed in that
question so it's actually pretty lucky
if you get two marks for doing the same
thing twice we usually try and give you
two months between two different things
but we did this question so badly I'm
sort of filming a little bit of sympathy
of it okay you've got to hear a lot of
people got to you so let you have them
make years where we were all just sort
of fell to pieces okay at this point you
identify that any coefficient of x over
four that's what I'm asking
so you thought alright I should pick a
value of R that gives me X to the four
okay now once you have a figure out this
another D then R equals zero are
introduced does it give you an X to the
porter in this case none right because
of the way that I've written it out
could speak about it if this is to the
power of zero you just get a constant
here if that's a zero this is a two in
here and a four outsides of all DiPaola
be it we ate okay so you have to abandon
that so you start to piece through a lot
of you actually started to put together
an equation to solve
you would have either gotten depending
on the way that you are depending on the
exact weight we phrases because it's
more than one most of you landed on to
some people then no one there in a read
way you can do where you can write a
zero right his problem though all of you
for almost all of you check one I think
said okay I found the value for example
for this one right does this work in our
case
if I go to plus x squared just think
about one that extensions g plus x
squared so that's a squared plus 2 a B
plus B's but yeah right this what are
you gonna get this minus this will be
negative x squared to the power of what
remember I'm thing about R equals 2 so
that negative x squared times negative x
squared 1 goes to the negatives by the
way they go on because it's exactly two
of them right and in that gives you X to
the 4 okay
this whole thing is being multiplied by
this
so ask the question again do you get an
extra fortune it's something you do from
this guy times this guy okay these guys
are useless to you they make the power
to that but this one's good okay but the
followers it's not the only one it's not
the only value of R that gives you in X
to the 4 term for instance if you
haven't think about the tunnel look at
our equals well pick another one pick
another one what are you going to get
out of this there's a little bit harder
because you like more terms right but
you can still do this I think about your
binomial coefficients right and then
think about how many of each of these
you're going to get okay if we're to the
car three I'm going to go with eight
some just put this the next one along
will be 4x right I'm climbing down the
numbers and I'm climbing up the exits
one of an intimate 2x squared and the
last one
excuse and so these are all multiplied
and don't get the actual coefficients
honestly this is what I'll get from here
we're tryna equal C what are you going
to get from you when R equals three have
a look I think it's just it's just
negative x squared okay now every term
here will get multiplied by this guy
right do you get next to the 4 out of
this ant I guess you do between this
game and this guy and this is what we
simplified this is why it's a bit
challenging you're almost certainly
either got one mark this year or three
months because you've got to the end if
you only got one of these you actually
made two mistakes right number one you
missed it you missed that there are
other values that got you the actual
excellent water that you're after but
then because that you have simplified
the question traumatically there's so
much less work to do if you only say I'm
just going to look at one of them and
then I'm going to go home okay going
through this process is where the work
is and it's why do pretty much about one
or three it's very hard to get to
because if you did all this work you did
end up at the end and I think if you
gather all of these let's go to three
but actually well maybe when I got down
this this is the way that I actually run
down the excellent fourth term equals
and by the way I said on Monday a lot of
you are not just a lot of you a lot of
it gray was violating the equal sign
because they would write from so
extension right and then they would
notice what I'm looking for only these
things right so then the next line they
would say equals and then they would
only write the X plus four terms and
they just ignore the rest of them well
these things are no longer equal right
so I'm stopping that line of working and
I'm saying okay now only focusing on
this part this is what I ended up with
we just had a look at two of them
briefly values of R that give you an X
to the four term there is a third one
okay
so you can see when you've got one two
three and you can actually see my values
of R that are in the ways I've arranged
them okay once you've got all the values
of R there was the second mark that was
the second month one
and then from here you can see which one
is it going to be this is going to be 24
I think that's probably - it's six six
times four what we're going to hear for
C 3 that's 4 so 4 times 6 times negative
1 it's 2048 is negative 24 there so
these guys exactly cancel which leaves
you with what's force before it's one so
you get this guy so the coefficient
you're after
so I said before the rest of the part of
this question required routine but this
there's lots of places to go wrong so
I'll forgive you music and trouble with
this one but no you're going this again
then the next time you can try as hard
but now you know how to do it okay